[Music]
rachel's with us in tulsa oklahoma hi
rachel how are you
i'm doing okay thank you dave for taking
my call sure what's up
yeah so i am a 28 year old and just
graduated with my bachelor's degree in
leadership you're you're 20 what year
old say that again
28 28 years old okay
yes and i graduated with my bachelor's
in leadership studies
made about thirty thousand and a hundred
twenty thousand in debt i've tried to
make a budget but it's not working so
seeking your advice what do you mean
it's not working
like my income is
some days some weeks i get overtime and
sometimes i don't so my income is just
it's not set
so
setting the budget is really difficult
okay well there's a way to budget for
irregular income but it sounds like to
me it's it's more of a problem than just
that do you just not are you not able to
make your bills on your income
barely yeah
what do you do
i work for um i'm in retail
i work at autozone okay and you got a
degree for 120 000 in leadership studies
well that and car loan and medical debt
credit card how much of the 120 is
student loans
100 of it okay
all right so what is the game plan to
put that education to work to make more
than 30k at autozone
i am trying to
you know put my resume out and get into
the field
just there's been no you know my resume
hasn't gotten any hits on it for
interviews okay what are you what are
you applying for
any job that comes up
okay
rachel i i hear in your voice and maybe
i'm wrong here but i hear in your voice
that it sounds like you are taking a a
more passive approach to this job search
than i want you to
you have to get your income up
significantly
if you're going to get out of 120 000 in
debt so that could be working three
retail jobs or you could just land a
really good job and then maybe some
extra side gigs uh that gets your income
up but it's going to take
knocking the door down it's going to
take i'm going to email you my resume
i'm going to apply online i may hand
deliver a resume on beautiful resume
paper as well and bring you some coffee
while i'm at it like you are going to
find the people that you want to work
with using the skills that you have the
the connections you want to make the
companies that you want to work for i
don't know what it looks like but you
have got to get scrappy and determined
to get your foot in the door a job is
not going to appear on your lap so
someone lied to you
they told you that if you went and got a
degree in leadership studies that
someone would hire you to be a leader
i know i have to work you know start at
the bottom yeah and that was that was a
lie
and then the second thing so what you're
going to need to do is narrow your focus
in on what you want to be
doing when you're 38 what does a decade
from now rachel look like
and then what are these steps for me to
get there the leadership degree in
leadership studies is not a bad degree
it just doesn't come with a guarantee of
prosperity
or a guarantee that it's going to
automatically open up the resume door in
a digital world so let me give you a
couple things one is i'm going to give
you ken coleman's book
the proximity principle and he ken does
a show here at the ramsey networks on
finding a job and finding a career and
getting plugged into your career also i
want you to go to kencoleman.com i want
you to download all of his resume
templates and all of his free tools he's
got a ton of stuff there that's going to
help you get your foot in the door
somewhere doing one specific type of
thing if you just say i'll work anywhere
that pays more money no one will hire
you i don't want to hire you if that's
your goal
if i'm an employer i'll hire 300 people
here this year and i won't hire you to
do anything that makes more money than
autozone i don't have a job description
that's that
i have a job description that says i
need this certain thing done can you do
this certain thing and are you
passionate about this certain thing oh
by the way 300 people will get hired 24
000 applications will come in digitally
so guess what you got no chance
just filling out applications
zero chance
you could be the daughter of the
president of the united states and
you've got zero chance getting 500 300
out of 24 000. you have to do something
else that sets yourself apart in this
world you can't just monster.com your
way into this it doesn't work
and so um you got to get somebody inside
the building that is at the place that
you want to work doing the thing that
you want to do that gets your foot in
the door i had a young lady apply here
uh for a marketing position two weeks
ago and within 48 hours i had four of my
friends email me and say hey so-and-so's
daughter has applied there please get
her name out of the stack
now i didn't hire her because of that
but it got her an interview
and it got her past the stack
and i don't even know if we hired her
yeah and i truthfully i
i don't tell my guys they have to hire
somebody the daughter of my friend or
whatever but i do want him to at least
give her a look out as a courtesy and if
they're friends of christie's they're
going to get a look at a courtesy of her
friends at kelly's are going to get a
look out of courtesy and that doesn't
mean we're going to hire them but it
gets you out of the 24 to 300 stack you
know that's how i got here i applied for
a position 12 years ago in our event
team and got an auto response that
position had been filled started
reaching out to anybody that i knew that
worked here or anybody that you knew
that knew somebody that's right and
started having a conversation after
conversation that led to a job posting
that led to what i'm doing you've got to
get more determined you got to get more
determined rachel if you're going to get
a job you've got it's not going to
that's what i mean by somebody lied to
you you made you think this was going to
be easy
um it's not it's going to be really hard
it's just going to be worth it hang on
kelly i'll pick up we'll send you a copy
of ken coleman's book and we'll help you
with this get on his website start
listening to ken coleman podcast i think
magically you will get a job if you'll
do exactly the stuff he tells you to do
this is the ramsay show